c'est quoi le sujet en vo pour le sujet
c'est une femme en l'occurrence et
isabelle huppert qui a été trompé par
béatrice d'air qui était sa meilleure
amie
le mari de d'isabelle huppert est mort
et
isabelle décide de se venger de se
venger à mort ouais raconté comme ça ça
a l'air facile
c'est dur quand même deux heures et
quart ces courants pour une vengeance
ouais tu l'as vu non non je je je crains
la voix j'irai le voir en tête toujours
cette image comme ça à peu la pelouse
peu triste serghini coup c'est ta vraie
nature
non c'est mon faux c'est ma vraie nature
parfois c'est ma nature
quand je suis à paris d'ailleurs quand
je suis non mais comme je suis à paris
quand je vais en promo c'est vrai qu'il
ya tout le temps si j'ai pris l'avion il
ya trois quatre heures et je suis encore
d'accord la moitié de moi même qui à
clermont ferrand ce que je suis un peu
un peu absent dans la présence quand
même
ouais bon les gens m'accusent de
macaluso marange stats on constate que
ça mais c'est que je suis contre je vais
demander c'est un gimmick non touchés
c'est et les migraines chroniques la
vega line ouais c'est ça c'est plus sain
aujourd'hui je suis en pleine migani pas
fait ça et donc plus prendre des trucs
et ce à trois ans comme ça ouais c'est
la coudée c'est là que mason web je suis
sûr tant les coups reçus en quoi parce
qu'une fois tu as dit je dois passer
pour un pauvre petit picchu c'est quand
même bien que tu le sais quand même
non mais c'est je pense que j'ai intégré
c'est dans un charme de mecs vous seront
très bien roulé mais qu'il faut alors
qu'est ce qui va sortir le disque là
dans les semaines qui viennent 45 jours
l'ail et le prochain 45 tours qui a
gardé près de moi qui sort dans quelques
jours je continue la promo sur l'album
you rang il y aura un prochain 40
centres au plus tard au printemps que
sinon je prépare le prochain album début
avril atelier avec gts que tu es prêt
pour le blind test
ouais ouais ouais